[Música]
votaram não espera uma recessão que ele
mais calorosa muito né é faca na minha
filha mais velha tinha 6 anos foi para
escola normal e na primeira semana de
aulas chega em casa triste e eu
perguntei por que o que passa não estava
a gostar da escola
não estou triste porque a pessoa não
deixou pintar o sol conta rosa tinha que
ser amarela
eu pensei cá pra mim ele está grave
grave da história simples mas acho que o
fundamental é acertar algumas coisas que
não está muito bem no sistema educativo
para assumir um pouco vou aguentar forte
ao longo do tempo tem uma pesquisa que
está muito mais do que eu pensava
a situação é grave
grava e eu não sei que é mais grave
você nós não estávamos a dar ouvido
perguntamos o que eles querem ver que
estamos a considerar os como uma espécie
de humanos de segunda que não tem nada a
acrescentar na construção do espaço que
é principalmente deus é praia onde os
atores principais
só porque são pouco provável que eu
venho aqui a comentar hoje é que eu
acredito que estamos a alienar pessoas
tomando todo e todos os anos a alienar
milhões e milhões de empregos do que o
cheiro é o máximo de seu potencial e
isso é uma espécie de organização e
vocês sabem do que estou a falar a todos
eu falava que o garoto tem 21 mas não
tem vontade de acordar de manhã e passou
aqui hoje tem seis erros eventuais
conselhos e ficam completamente
diferente nos pode ficar enfrentam sair
daqui o que é mais grave ainda está
chorando por conta 18 e 18 final não
chega para que o curso que nem sequer
sabem se querem ou não temos coisas mais
importantes para fazer a estrutura está
treinando toda a gente tem é que tive
neste momento está a triturar alunos de
triturar o professor
isso é uma espécie viu em campo em
aceitar prendas sabe muito bem que eu
vou dizer que haverá como meta comenta
com mimi
o teste é bullying é uma forma de
impedir que eu faço bem estar que é
bullying que acumulem isso é bobo e mia
induzir o vômito e chega porque estamos
a triturar uma coisa que é fundamental
eu procurei durante muito tempo o que
quer saber fundamental está por baixo da
construção toda do ser e eu acho que
encontrei e procurar muito para
encontrar a mesma coisa que muitas obras
já têm encontrará tanto anos 50 anos
ela encontrou mais valia ter lido os
livros dela mas é fato a escolha
eu acredito que o que está a factos
provados da construção é a escolha que é
precisamente a única coisa que a gente
não deixou de fazer escolher depois
teremos autonomia
queremos responsabilidade
responsabilidade sobre o que se escolhe
não foi dentro é patente ser mais
criativo criaram que isto não pode
escolher escolho a escola escolheu
guarda esta palavra agora para suas
escolhas
é preciso um ambiente um carinho
diferente da que o tempo é preciso um
ambiente onde eu me sinta seguro para
fazer as minhas escolhas
quando eu erro em vez de estar a ser
penalizado pelo erro
eu sou livre o erro como aquilo que é
quando eram seja sobrado como motor
primeiro em primário tudo que a
aprendizagem porque quem é certa não
aprendeu nada com certa já sabe isso
estar aqui quero fazer coisas não vamos
fazer coisas inovadoras estados a criar
mais errar mais errada e limpe os cortes
não são aquelas que não é que não
queiramos quer não fazer que não quer
nunca tá bom tá puxando pois até então
sempre claro não foge quem nunca erra
está muito baixo realizar o potencial eu
porque não está sequer perto do limite
no limite do erro
se tu não quero ser o primeiro sinal
estava abaixo do seu potencial muito
muito os fortes emoções que não eram de
caen foram então às vezes enquanto a
banda estréia na copa
esperava contar com o chão com pontapés
chama certa sempre aponta para a lua e
uma estrela irá contar com o chamamento
não chega nem perto agravado e por si só
o hino tem ocorrido é nojento currículo
mas o currículo por si só é inútil
eu sei que muita gente concorda com isto
não podemos ter todos os anos me
perguntar a mim pá afixaram do núcleo do
átomo que vão fazer combater o gênio
aqui embaixo resolver o problema da
energia
o mesmo currículo
mas mobiliar a casa toda bonitinha com
os fase e depois lá os ladrões estavam
em cima do sofá da casa não tem paredes
nem os sérvios que está a fazer o que
estava fazendo e vão andar a atirar -
paterna para tratar da terra primeiro
natural por cima das pedras na china
chega a três anos disse pra mim chega
já andava a namorar a metodologia da
aprendizagem baseada em projetos para
uma coisa gira já não queria que eu vou
fazer o que tenho que fazer é nos três
anos é paraense não tá na hora tá na
hora eu já experimentei aqui nestas
caixinhas formuladas engenheiros e
técnicos grosso está na hora de
implementar na moda todo vinhos nota vem
não tudo bem eu tenho que ir andando
agora é fácil a gente está fazendo aqui
muita gente que passou por lá é fácil
que a gente está fazendo não é bom para
quem você é e não é fácil agora que a
série é difícil e foi muito bem nas
costas e que este plano que não sabe
muito bem quando entrou nas costas
enquanto as obras ficarão sem dormir mas
não primou a ninguém
vamos mostrar a casa que estamos a fazer
pensei muito sobre o que a minha fazer
hoje mas depois acabei proferir eu vou
mostrar a casa que estamos a fazer
porque no fundo é minha jogada resolveu
construir uma casa primeiro em tallin
que possamos colher evidente mas não é
com o sistema educativo para assentar a
casa em cima do crédito muitas resultado
ajustado já muitas partes minutos já
podemos ser alteradas para que tem 600
anos
algumas têm de assentar as coisas em
cima da realidade e do tipo de
competência que estou precisando renan e
positiva da realidade nós vamos assentar
aquela que a coisa fundamental aquela
palavrinha campos disse que aguardaria o
caso vamos colocar aqui
a escolha é fundamental tanto em
publicações em formato tv e escolhe o
que vai fazer parte do currículo que vai
desenvolver com profundidade para
desenvolver quanto tempo quer ficar aqui
o jogo faz essa escolha das cores mas
antes quer dedicar mais a mim pode ficar
mais muito mais do que pode
as pessoas têm que fazer a escolha e
assumir a responsabilidade de terem
feito funciona e por que é que fazemos
escolhas que a palavra porque fazemos
porque acontece
sabemos que vivemos e falamos claro dois
pilares essenciais porque não havia
armado em pilar
fazemos muitas coisas
tentamos aprender muitas coisas a média
caiu pelo ensino nada não dou mal a ela
no dia 30 uma coisa está a ser gravado
aqui deixando de pagar mas não dou um
google apagou eu aprendi bem sozinho não
se prendem mas sozinho não sair
isto vai parar em outra cama linha que
liga tudo que é a camada da
responsabilidade e agora sim temos o
primeiro andar completo escolhe não foge
da responsabilidade por ter escolhido
faso e tem um ambiente onde pode falhar
pode falhar
falei com eles não falem comigo que eu
tô vendo uma baixa parece um caso
suspeito
podem falar com ele e agora por cima
desse primeiro andar é factível
nós começamos a construir a competência
por exemplo uma fundação sólida e nós
estamos um bocado orientados ao
tentarmos orientar aqui hoje os 46 que é
um em 46 são colaboração comunicação e
pensamento crítico do fato os quadros
que são consideradas mais fundamentais
para 430 50 anos não sabia que o mais
que aceitamos mais tudo o que seja fácil
tudo pior revés tudo seja
desenvolvimento como esse possa ser o
lema do título no ano passado era puxar
que fizemos certo tempo já que o
webshield otávio
é tanto eo prime twist e às vezes à
custa do currículo empatar e puxamos que
não tem nada a ver com o meu currículo
bom trabalho
continuo a não tem problema nenhum
ocorreu quando eles precisarem lá vão
aprender o resto fato e por cima das
competências claro pode acontecer
aprendizagem e se calhar não consegue
parar contente de aprendizagem é uma
espiral respirar aprendizagem incluindo
os currículos mas também a aprendizagem
de competências e tenhamos a casa assim
que está nos damos conta que se prestava
criado sentia nenhuma casa
então tentamos fazer uma coisa que eu
acho que já deu frutos
precisa de melhorias nós trabalhamos
todos os anos a experimentar com a
própria construção da disciplina
experimentamos tentamos fazer melhorias
que fizemos um pianinho do metal
aprendizagem e passamos com um ponto em
que não estamos só aprender
nós temos momentos de reflexão séria
sobre como é que o prendem como é que o
prêmio porque aprender f para saber como
é que eu aprendo o setor na consciência
maneira como eu aprendo eu posso
manipular esse processo ao tentar
manipular e tornar o melhor e ser cada
vez mais eficiente aprender e só isso é
que vai transformar numa pessoa autônoma
só isso é que vai transformar numa
pessoa autônoma depois com autonomia
eu consigo atingir mais patamar a
patamar de transformação não quer deitar
fora tudo que existe o que existe em lei
essas pessoas
existe uma parte da editora e muitas
delas área mas isto transforma este
sujeito transformar se permita o sujeito
fazer uma coisa mágica do transformar se
transcender e agora tá ali um pacotinho
roupa né porque se juntarmos
transformação e transcendência
vamos ter uma coisa que vocês já ouviram
que o nome hoje anunciam as duas
palavras mas é fato que essa palavra
significa
vamos ter educação
os três segundos para pensar nisso é
fato porque educação e o próprio rei
latina da palavra educação conta por aí
o querer é trazer o sujeito para fora
dele não ter currículo na cabeça do
sujeito é trazer o sujeito cá para fora
o sujeito transformar-se e transcender e
saída é o próprio começar a agir sobre o
mundo à volta de 11 horas de hoje as
pessoas que fazem o comando eu agradeço
e tal mas o dado não é uma coisa que eu
não tinha o estranho ter uma conversa
séria e de repente você acha que a gente
andava à procura de entrada no primeiro
dispositivo chamado à procura do coração
e eu acho que o coração
gostávamos escolha ao pé da escolha
claro como é evidente que nós não
andamos a brincar
nós não andamos a brincar nas aplicações
informáticas respeitarmos o coração não
significa que vamos brincar agora eu
aqui estou agora várias palavras de uma
pessoa mais importante que o pai chamada
jobs steve jobs ea prová-lo
assumidamente não tem problema nenhum
ig mas passaram a maior parte da sua
vida a trabalhar eu não quero que ela
com isso temos que ser mais produtiva
não vamos andar veio muito pior não é
isso que apresentará placas informativas
trabalhamos como quem vai passar a maior
parte da vida trabalhar e tudo só vai
ser feliz a trabalhar não vai ser feliz
a trabalhar vai passar a maior parte da
vida infeliz pode passar a maior parte
virá trabalhar tanto convencer fui
trabalhar
isso só vai ser feliz a trabalhar quando
tiver de fazer coisas que realmente são
relevantes proteína coisas que te
entregam coisas fazem mexer aqui dentro
e portanto isso é coisa mais importante
para fazer a tua vida toda em 1988 98
mas sempre há tempo a coisa mais
importante para fazer ouvir todas é
descobrir aquilo que te mexe naquilo que
faz mexer os ponteiros aqui ela a
empregabilidade
basta descobrir disso tudo mas arranjar
maneira de tornar lucrativo muito mais
do que um teste no emprego das novas
cinco encontra aquilo que faz um cheiro
coraçã limpinho é coisa mais importante
que tem que fazer
o professor estuda trabalha e trabalha
exclusivamente uma das motivações no
ensino navios vão eles conseguem
muita gente diz que o estudo não tem
nada de rasputin não tem nada de errado
precisam é carro descendo a correção
passando de coração e saiu na frente já
virão com o ser humano é capaz de
motivar sendo a decoração está na frente
e funciona e funciona e é lindo e sair
daquela do currículo dos testes no
sistema educativo no mundo muda a equipa
cada um tem que mudar o próprio é um
crime que está muito em cima do tempo e
portanto deixem só fazemos ao final
agressiva para o organismo
vamos tentar fazer o que fizeram todas
as gerações organismo enquanto tem força
organismo
estou aqui isto não é o cine teatro de
alcobaça portugal no mundo todo
vocês não podem deixar de investir em si
nunca em circunstância alguma aceitar
menos do que isso e não amanhã hoje não
é mais ninguém
isto
[Aplausos]
hum
i